[Music]
hey guys in this video I'm bringing the
alleged leaked outline for the second
episode of the final season of Game of
Thrones as I did for the season 8
premiere I will share the alleged leaked
outline and try to break it down event
by event of which most are seemingly
supportive in many leaks the alleged
outline episode 2 claims that it starts
with Jaime Lannister jimmyrh I've said
the twins it's a small an Easter army he
rallied most of the Riverlands house
Tolly Blackwood may Lister and Bracken
Jamie's here to rally the freight
soldiers to Jamie as free girls what
happened there sir free response with
winter came for House Frey
I gotta stop right there to point out
that extras Daniel Callaghan has been
cast as a character named Sara in George
RR Martin's source material Sara's a
granddaughter of Walder Frey a
ginger-haired Sara Frey has already
debuted very briefly in Game of Thrones
back in the show's third season and
before the read varying Walder Frey told
Robb Stark that he could have had an
option of marrying Sarah her twin sister
Sarah or both for all I care better
discipline turns out to be real or fake
fragrant Sarah will definitely make an
appearance in the final season on Game
Jones the outline then visits King's
Landing Cersei grows more mad and
paranoid after the miscarriage more
ruthless Qyburn enter chambers but
Cersei doesn't want to speak
Qyburn speaks about Meggie the frogs
prophecy Cersei smiles skin stop
laughing
Cersei says something along the lines
such a pity Lord Ranelagh for he'll
hunted her down I never got a chance to
tell her how wrong she was three
children shall I bear piece on your
prophecy goal shall be their crowns and
gold their shouts she was right but not
really I had four children through a
Jaime one with Robert
Qyburn responds with the one that died
as soon as he was born your grace Cersei
repeats after in the one that died and
smiles this part is very interesting to
me is she talking about ginjury perhaps
make his fate might also come as a
surprise to you killed by randyll Tarly
some years ago this magazine has
actually already been confirmed by Sammy
the prophecies of the known world which
is part of histories and lore a special
feature from game journals the complete
seventh season it's narrated by John
Bradley and similarly semi-new Moritz
and Rose prophecies playing Westeros and
Essos alike when I was a boy I were
heard to cook with spring - made about a
would switch camping outside home Hill
who was called Maggie the Frog now I
realize it was probably corruption of
the Eastern world for wizards Maggie
one day my father rode out hunting the
owner game was
season and whatever power she had likely
did not save her sam says anyways let's
continue with the outline it says that
half of the unsullied arrive at the
dreadfort let's add she writes of
interval in the form of an old woman
Danny is pregnant she orders from Sandy
a maester wolkan to stay quiet about it
honestly there's been many scenes
throughout the previous season
foreshadowing Danis pregnancy Vee Jones
know that this is not even coming as a
surprise and once again it's something
that will almost certainly come true no
matter of the legitimacy of this outline
an outline says Cersei gets a letter
this could be a letter Tyrion wrote and
said in secret in the season 8 premiere
you're on crazy on the Cylons hair
strickland and an experienced sailor
beside him he has a horn urine has blue
lips as blue as the White Walkers eyes
mark Chrisman has gotten company
commander hair strickland and an unknown
actor that was casted for a sailor but a
casting call requesting a sailor age 35
to 50 a rough and ready seafaring type
with a feathered face and strong
presence once again real or fake both of
these new characters have been confirmed
to appear at some point into the final
season brains got the serious ovations
from the past present future the net
king flies Vissarion present
Cersei gives birth to a black haired son
and has replaced a man wears a hood past
Regan Robert fight past when FL burns
future out of these four different
visions from different outlines things
that happened are happening and that
will happen to have been confirmed to
actually play out in the final season
Winterfell will burn as confirmed by
leaked photos and regular flashbacks
will also likely happen not only the
George Armand state that there will not
be need for Robert's rebellion Rick will
show revealing that everything we need
to know and see from that time period
will be shown in game crowns basically
confirming that a legendary fight
between Rhaegar and Robert will like to
be included in the last six episodes but
an actor who plays Rhaegar has been
shooting scenes for season 8 the
attendant states that we have a huge
meeting in the main hall of interval
army of that is not marching to the
dreadfort as we expected they're
marching on us all 100,000 of them
except for the night king who is flying
as Aryan South says bran
Tyrion doubts in principalities where
exactly did you see them as Danny above
Harrenhal response brain then that's
where I'll go then he says during
interrupts this conversation and says if
you take half of our armies to hunt down
the night king Winterfell is doomed
Jon Snow in the northern Lords agree
they are solid or the track against
bazarian air is useful as whites against
Jorgen in riga you need every single man
to stand a chance against the army of
the
they stay here of light Rogen in regal
south and I will kill this night king
and Viserion stays Danny Jon s Tyrion if
his CERN sources are mr. marching to
their aid sense expresses our doubt
about sirs his intentions Turner shares
everyone that his sister will help brain
interrupts and claims that since there's
his armies in Norway them in the war to
come
a northern century interrupts the
meeting he tells John the Delano army
led by Sir Jaime Lannister is marching
on foot and has just passed castle
serving and should be other gates by the
nightfall many start doubting brain and
his visions John says we need to prepare
our defenses the army of the Dead is
only days away
praying in Rab John and says we must
retreat south Winterfell will fall
I saw it burning there's many things
happening I'll try to break it all down
so brain shares vision with all the Lord
some believe some doubt him then he
believes they attend she is apparently
going to chase the night king brain says
he saucers his armies sailing north and
the Norton sentry says that the
Lannister army is marching on foot and
will arrive by the nightfall having
already passed castle serving basically
what's happening is that brain so the
lynnster armies sailing north with urine
in the going company is likely not
coming - it's a the auto brain says it
does although in stir army that is
marching on foot and that is actually
coming - it's a it is the one led by
Jamie a small army he rallied in the
Riverlands
once again real or fake some parts of
the South line are confirmed to happen
in the final season and such is the
appearance of the northern century Frank
Blake was casted and filmed the scene as
you guessed it the northern century
after having said that the Lancer Army's
selling nord some started our brains
abilities and visions especially after
receiving news of the Lannister army
marching on foot unaware that it's two
different armies led by different
commanders one coming to aid them and
the other to fight them the meeting ends
it brain saying is vision of future
interval burning and mourning them they
must retreat south while there's still
time
of course John and others will not
listen the battle for Winterfell is
happening and is the largest battle
sequence ever filmed even if John and
others probably believe in brans visions
they still have to try and defend the
north and they will although not
successfully Bren can't see the future
but he cannot change it it's got to
happen otherwise it would not be the
future and bran would see it some of you
probably wonder if bran can say things
which he can how come he did not see
Jamie leading armies as well or how come
he doesn't see search these armies that
by yearning here is a threat and not as
the promised state by Queen Cersei how
come he does no sir sister intentions
get many fans confused with brain being
that we had Raven people think he knows
everything that's happened or is
happening which simply is not true to
explain him better let's take a look on
how the actor who plays bran stark
explained how exactly sparks work on
games runs the way Prince power works at
the moment is that his basically got the
Kindle library of the whole history of
the universe he says he just hasn't read
every book yet and the old way Raven has
sat in a tree for a thousand years and
read through every piece of history and
his access at all he continues with but
for now he needs people to tell me what
they want him to see that's exactly how
brains so John's parents being married
in a secret ceremony someone told him to
check out if this happen he accessed it
and he confirmed it he doesn't know
everything but he can go and check it
out and I'm glad the show will explain
in the next season because they've got
many people confused basically what
happens in this case is that brain store
on sailing with Circe's arm is north and
by hearing that Cersei promised to send
help he assumes that they're coming to
the north side however no one told brain
to go back and check out sure she
explains that she discussed it you're in
the leader of the gun company and to
check if they're really coming to the
north side perhaps episode three will
not see the living fighting the death
only perhaps the living will fight among
themselves after all your own promise
Cersei to destroy the pretenders in the
north the outline continues with
seemingly destroyed own story coming
back into play Dorne is led by a new
character who is not a Martell fifteen
thousand Dornishmen arrive this new
character that will adorn has also been
confirmed to appear in the final season
since he said not to be a Martell I have
no idea who this character might be
however I may know who this mysterious
character might be played by Tobey
Osmond is casted for a royal role and I
think he might be playing this new
Dornish leader who was seemingly rarely
dawn and get 15,000 Dornishmen to the
capital before the end of episode two
having in mind a Dornishmen ton
especially like Lannisters
they're probably storming King's Landing
although there's still a small
possibility that they came to serve
filthy to Queen Cersei of House
Lannister back to the outline at
Winterfell Howland Reed arrives with
3,000 crannogmen when our family's honor
preparations everyone builds dragonglass
weapons burke teaches a small group how
to ignite their swords yet again legit
or not it's already been confirmed that
multiple people will will flaming swords
in the battle against the dead by many
leaked photos here we can see at least
three people with flaming swords all
three on horseback the last scene on the
episode is in the crypts of interval
John's Tom and Danny are in the crypts
they discuss Annette's death they're
later joined by Howland
then he leaves the tool to speak alone
Helen talks about Lena Stark
he says something along the line Lena
stark the wolf girl first met her the
great tourney at Harrenhal it's a
beautiful story that one through a
squire so larger than me a small
crannogmen started to be me until you
and I came to my defense she attacked
them with the turn his sword can you
believe it the bullies scattered and
Liana took me back to her tent there I
met up with tethered and benjin and
Brandon Liana protected me and they
returned a favor now that you're grown
men with not read other than the dead I
think Liana would want you to know this
Liana is not your before Howland could
reveal Jon the truth behind his
parentage the horn is being blown
episode two ends
that's an interesting end of this
alleged leaked outline of the second
episode of the final season this entire
scene in the crypts might have been
confirmed by the leaks it was like that
episode two will see the return of the
crypts which was being filmed on its
long-standing location at Shane's castle
it was also reported that two main
characters so discussed Ned Stark's
death in this scene even the scene
ending with a home being blown has been
confirmed so once again real or fake
something like this will definitely take
place in episode two the main question I
have is how many times this horn being
blown who is arriving the army of the
Dead finally reached Winterfell is a
Jamie or is it your own in the golden
company so many questions all in all a
leaked outline for episode 2 does seem
interesting and if true this episode
will be full of events and quite a long
one let me know what you think about
this alleged outline in the comment
section down below and as always I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace
[Music]